todavía nos quedan por resolver como
unos 15 problemas entonces vamos ahora
con el 66 dice en el diagrama la medida
del ángulo a es igual a 32 grados
y lo marcan y hace es igual a 10 así es
igual a 10 en la ecuación se puede usar
para encontrar x en el triángulo abc abc
otra vez es trigonometría vamos a
ponerle por aquí
después tenemos que aprender a ya no
escribirlo verdad pero bueno vamos a
ponerlo sujeto a y lo que queremos hacer
es encontrar x entonces tenemos este
ángulo de acá 32 grados y tenemos este
lado que es el cateto adyacente y lo que
nosotros queremos es el cateto opuesto
entonces sería bueno tener una función
trigonométricas que relaciona el cateto
opuesto con el adyacente y esa justo es
tangente tenemos que tangente de 32
grados 32 grados es igual a opuesto o
sea x bc / adyacente o sea hace x entre
hace que mide 10 y a partir de aquí
podemos obtener x multiplicando por 10
de ambos lados 10 tangente de 32 grados
de 32 grados es igual a equis vamos a
ver si está por aquí en algún lugar esa
opción si opción c x es igual a 10
tangente de 32 grados al parecer esta
idea de eso kato es muy simple pero nos
está ayudando muchísimo eso incluso
funciona en muchos otros lugares no sólo
ahorita para encontrar estas medidas
sino después cuando hagamos identidades
trigonométricas
también todo se va a reducir a shock a
tomar pero bueno vamos a seguir mientras
con los problemas que tenemos vamos con
el 67 zocato es súper útil bueno en
triángulos rectángulos aquí son puros
triángulos rectángulos después
platicaremos un poco de triángulos en
general y funciones trigonométricas con
ley de senos ley de cosenos pero ahorita
no me voy a meter en esos son puros
triángulos rectángulos bueno ahora sí 67
el diagrama muestra una escalera de 8
pies recargada en la pared ésta ha de
ser la escalera mide 8 pies la escalera
hace un ángulo de 53 grados con la pared
este ángulo de acá nos preguntan cuál es
el valor más cercano a la altura del
punto donde la escalera toca la pared o
sea nos piden que encontremos esta
altura de acá esta altura de acá vale
vamos a llamarle nos digamos x entonces
esta altura va a ser x bueno pues que
tenemos tenemos la medida de este ángulo
tenemos la hipotenusa y tenemos el
cateto adyacente entonces voy a poner su
cato a lo mejor ya no bueno si todavía
voy a poner su cato a voy a poner aquí
eso
entonces queremos encontrar una función
trigonométricas que relacione adyacente
con hipotenusa javier adyacente esté
adyacente con hipotenusa escocés bueno
entonces vamos a poner coseno de 53
grados coseno de 53 grados es igual a
cateto adyacente o sea x / hipotenusa
que es 8 entre 8 vale de esta forma x es
igual a coseno de 53 grados multiplicado
por 8 y aquí nos dicen que podemos usar
que cosenos de 53 grados aproximadamente
es 0.60 entonces x aproximadamente es
igual a 4.8 4.8 pies pies
esa es la opción b
vamos ahora el problema 68 problemas 68
a continuación se muestra el triángulo j
k l j k l y el rectángulo muy bien
preguntan que ecuación se debe usar para
encontrar a la longitud de jk j k es
este segmento es este segmento de aquí
pues mismísima idea verdad vamos a
seguir usando zocato ah bueno creo que
aquí nada más basta porque tenemos 24 y
queremos relacionar el cateto opuesto
con la hipotenusa y la función que
relaciona eso es seno seno es show seno
de 24 grados
seno de 24 grados es igual a opuesto o
sea jk jk / hipotenusa o sea 28 28 vamos
a ver si esta es la forma que quieren si
parece ser que sí entonces a b
a nuestra ansiedad al seno de 24 grados
es jk entre 28 entonces la respuesta es
a al parecer estos problemas están muy
rápidos de resolver 69 cual es la altura
aproximada en pies del árbol de la
figura a este problema está padre porque
nos da un ejemplo en el cual son útiles
las funciones trigonométricas por
ejemplo esto también funciona para las
estrellas y cosas de ese estilo
algunas veces si tenemos un objeto y
conocemos qué tan lejos está y el ángulo
con el cual lo estamos viendo entonces
podemos deducir pues qué tan alto o qué
tan largo es vale bueno entonces otra
vez estés trigonometría sólo que ahora
es un problema de aplicación pero está
muy facilito verdad nos piden encontrar
la altura del árbol deja de llamarle a
esa altura h no a lo mejor h no es buena
idea para no confundirla con la
hipotenusa vamos a ponerle o porque es
el cateto opuesto a este ángulo de 50
grados
entonces nos preguntan por la altura
aproximada queremos relacionar el cateto
opuesto con la hipotenusa otra vez
tenemos que usar seno que no es sólo
entonces seno de 50 grados
seno de 50 grados es igual a cateto
opuesto o sea o entre hipotenusa que es
100 que es 100 entonces o sin haber si
no se confunde con un 0 bueno lo bueno
es que estoy hablando también verdad
entonces o es igual a 100 x seno de 50
grados y aquí abajo nos dicen que seno
de 50 grados aproximadamente es 0.7 66
entonces
es igual a 100 por 7.6 7.6 entonces
bueno esto es aproximadamente igual
entonces o es aproximadamente igual a 76
vamos a ver si está en las opciones este
es el más cercano es que nos dicen que
es seno de 50 grados es es 0.7 66
entonces aquí puedo poner otros 6 y aquí
pondría 76.6 y entonces nos queda la
opción b muy bien creo que vamos muy
bien con estos de trigonometría si te
confunde un poco todo lo que estoy
haciendo y se te hace así súper rarísimo
te recomiendo que veas los vídeos que
hice en la lista de trigonometría ahí
explicó muy bien de dónde sale se enojó
se notan gente
salvo muchos problemas más a detalle
entonces pues ya sabes si estás un poco
confundido o no sabes qué rayos estoy
haciendo entonces puedes ir a esos
vídeos y bueno ya después regresar y ver
las cosas con más calma pero bueno
problemas 70
problemas 70 vamos a hacerlo con azul
marino porque no dice si a es igual a 3
raíz de 3 en el triángulo rectángulo de
abajo cuál es el valor debe a este es un
triángulo de 30 60 90 eso es también es
un concepto que viene en en la lista de
vídeos que hice estos triángulos son muy
importantes los que tienen ángulos 30
grados 60 grados y 90 grados este es de
60 grados porque 30 con 60 deben sumar
90 vale y lo que nos piden es determinar
el valor de b bueno ahorita no sabes qué
o se activa de alguna fórmula pero mejor
vamos a mostrar esa fórmula después con
un poco de práctica vas a poder resolver
este tipo de problemas muy rápido vas a
ver 30 60 90 y vas a saber qué hacer
inmediatamente pero ahorita vamos a
hacerlo con calma nos dicen que a a mide
3 raíz de 3 vale entonces la forma en la
cual a mí me gusta pensar esta figura es
pues reflejando este triángulo hacia la
izquierda entonces vamos a hacer esto
déjame prolongar este lado como está por
allá y lo que voy a hacer es reflejar
este tren reflejar jaja
reflejar este triángulo abc hacia allá
entonces quedaría más o menos algo de
este estilo más o menos algo así quizás
debería hacerlo un poco más bonito
ahí está bueno entonces es un ángulo
reflejado es igualito este ángulo es del
90 este es de 30 grados estoy acá es de
60 grados este lado mide 3 raíz de 33
raíz de 3 y éste mide ce pero observa
sucede algo interesante al hacer esta
reflexión nos queda aquí un triángulo un
triángulo grandote digamos abc en el
cual los tres ángulos son de 60 grados y
por lo tanto es un triángulo equilátero
esto está padre porque lo que nos dice
es que dos veces es lo mismo que se como
ave mide lo mismo que bc entonces
tenemos que dos veces a si lo voy a
escribir aquí en blanco dos veces a es
igual a c
eso está bueno porque a partir de ahí
podemos obtener el valor de ce ya
sabemos que se que es 3 raíz de 3
entonces es dos veces eso c es igual a 6
raíz de 3 y eso está bueno porque
conociéndose que es 6 raíz de 3 entonces
ahora tenemos este triángulo rectángulo
en el cual conocemos dos lados y por lo
tanto podemos calcular b que es la
hipotenusa déjame cambiar un color claro
para trabajar de este lado entonces
sabemos que al cuadrado más b cuadrada
es igual a c cuadrada pero al cuadrado
es 3 raíz de 3 23 raíz de 3 al cuadrado
más b cuadrada es igual a 6 raíz de 36
raíz de 3 al cuadrado que nos dice esto
3 raíz de tres al cuadrado es 9 por 3 o
sea 27 más b cuadrada es igual a 6 al
cuadrado es 36 por 3 36 por 3 108
entonces 27 más b cuadrada es igual a
108 por lo tanto b cuadrada es igual a
108 menos 27 que es igual a 81 y así bs
a 9 b es igual a 9 vale entonces tenemos
tenemos que a lo mejor puede buscar esta
herramienta para regresar a mi color
azul marino bonito tenemos que ver es
igual a 9 muy bien bueno este triángulo
de acá una vez más es súper conocido el
triángulo 30 60 90 y se sabe que sus
lados están en razón 1 a 2 a raíz de 3 y
eso es justo lo que acabamos de probar o
sea así ya supiéramos esto de antemano
como este es uno este es 2 y este es
raíz de 3 basta multiplicar esto por
raíz de 3 para obtener ve a ver si es
cierto 3 por raíz de tres por reid de 33
por 309 va entonces justo nos queda eso
mismo vale bueno otra vez si te parece
que estoy hablando en chino y no
entiendes a qué me refiero con 30 60 90
o si en general estos problemas de
trigonometría se complicaron te
recomiendo ir a la lista de vídeos de
trigonometría que tengo en la sección de
matemáticas y llegar a estas cosas con
un poco más de calma vale bueno
continuamos en el siguiente en el
siguiente vídeo con el problema número